you know what time it is
oh here he is what the disk with that
hey guys welcome to another episode of
risks of fury I'm Kelsey cook and today
I'm gonna be kicking Dean Delray's ass
at foosball thank you so much for doing
this today yeah absolutely the reason I
reached out was because you just posted
on your instagram this table of like
like long super foosball tables yeah
that was crazy yeah somebody actually
told me that that's a European version I
guess we're because it was like four
people play yeah it's a double table
yeah I didn't like it I know yeah I made
school ball purists so you said that
you've been playing for like a really
long time I had no idea well I haven't
played in probably 20 years oh my god
really but when I was a kid me and this
other kid named Mark garner Minh okay
would go to the scale mark yeah we would
go to the skating rink and this is in
70s burn I'm old I'm 52 like solo clap
for that that skin man you look great
and one day we showed up and they had
this table old school had clay men oh
god you could actually knock a guy's
head off they were made of clay the men
like Flintstones for yeah Wow and so we
started to learn the game we became
absolute killers Wow
I was obsessed with the skill of moving
the ball and being able to pass the ball
yeah and there's nothing better than
scoring from back here yeah I think
that's like the ultimate rock star like
big dick energy when you're scoring in
the back you're like oh I'm a god it's
like you know that POW you know and then
I got into my rock and roll my okay a
buddy of mine a coke dealer got one good
man yeah and we would go over and just
do coke and play like met like all night
oh my god coked up like Oh
and then I didn't play for years and now
here you are like you like knock the
dust off brush off these last 20 years
and well we're gonna go ahead and get
into this first game I got so many more
things I want to ask you as we play but
standard game first person to 5 ready
I'm excited play yeah so do you feel
like when you play it on coke that you
were better or worse oh pretty [ __ ]
pretty juiced up because I've never
played I'm such a square like I haven't
done anything besides an edible well
it's a lot of beer too you know like
here yeah a lot of people at the Maine
baseball tournaments will play with a
lot of booze in their system and I've
tried and I'm just I'm terrible with any
booze right
oh god damn you are [ __ ] around
you've got a really good shot this is
exciting
almost that was 20 years since you
played last right is this table weird to
you or no no I hated shitty tables I was
like a bent arm oh my god I will go into
bars and if I see a tables in bad shape
I can't oh yeah I will treat it like a
shelter animal I get so upset I'll go in
there with like olive oil all like make
the rods ride and people look at me like
I'm insane but nothing's sadder than an
abandoned physical table he's really
good this is like I'm actually having
trouble focusing and you just did Conan
for the first time I did it was
unbelievable it was awesome to watch you
you were fantastic
I was just sitting on the stage on the
side watching burn yeah and then okay
and then I got this call and it was an
unusual number and I was like who's that
I was gonna answer it was like Friday
night and I answered it and it was the
Conan people
yeah and they asked if I wanted to do
Conan
after that was nice a nice [ __ ] shot
if I wanted to do Conan I go yeah like I
just sent him the tape on Monday and
this is Friday oh [ __ ] okay oh my god
that's how fast you got it yeah and then
they go I go where and they got Monday
like oh oh right like four days later
yeah oh my god I did this Tonight Show
in March yeah and I had a month in
advance before yeah I did it and it was
almost like too much time and your story
with Conan was cool because you you
started doing comedy how many years ago
hey years ago years ago did you ever
think that that was gonna happen
yep you know absolutely that's why I
kept going when my friends are doing I
was like I've got to do Conan that's
like been your ultimate goal I wanted to
get Conan more than anybody and you
great did you grow up watching yeah
and I just loved like Jimmy I had Jimmy
on the podcast and I loved JP the guy
that book did and it was just so comedy
oriented you know and also they they
didn't you know they're not ageism you
know what I mean yeah they're not 52 and
it's real out there when I start a
comedy I didn't think age matter I was
doing showcases no one looking at me
sure
so you started to feel that that like
certain people will say no just because
of your age oh they weren't even looking
at me they weren't saying no oh when I
was like wait a minute
well that's shitty you know I'm not
complaining okay
all right so now we're gonna go into
game 2 where we have a bunch of
penalties so let's go draw some some
balls or see what chaos ensues all right
I was just warming up
you're really good all right let's see
so you and I let's each pick one mm [ __ ]
okay so you're gonna start with three
points yeah okay you swear I
automatically get a point okay you're
not the person that I would want to have
start with three points all right so
your start with three points no and
remember you can't swear
yep swear I think you know swear that
myself no I swear more than you I think
all right ready yeah okay makes me
nervous playing you I haven't had a like
play somebody really good on camera yet
easy so you have your podcast here on
all things comedy called leatherby talk
alright and how long you've been doing
that for six and a half years 400 and
something episode damn 400 yeah like
that and you've had some really big
guests on over the years yeah yeah I had
read Henry Rollins a couple of weeks ago
with one of my one of my idols burr
Marin you know yeah those are some big
names for sure who's your dream guest
that you haven't gotten on yet Oh would
they be like comedians or Rockettes oh
not comedians now I mean you know it's
we have Sean Penn did you hear Kurt I
said I'm taking a point it's cool that
you have that whole big rock background
in your life especially with foosball
because there is so much overlap there I
feel like you know yeah all right one
more one more
Homer point
do you remember having like a go-to shot
back in the day you mentioned banks yeah
I could be a lot of bad shots I just
haven't done him in so long
banks are really hard they feel good at
him really I want to feel like without a
bank
well I mean yeah I'd have to play for
like an hour you know it's like that was
awesome Oh for for real I can't even
speak right now if I could score from
the back on us okay so basically it's
like - oh right now but in this third
round it's sudden death so if you win
this you and everything oh so you can
redeem yourself but we're gonna play two
ball where you and I each start with a
ball and you have to score both balls in
order to get one point Wow so we're
gonna only play two three and there's
been some like special punishment I've
thought of if I beat you if you lose
yeah I get to post a picture of the
Spice Girls on your Instagram post a
long caption about how much you love the
Spice Girls and how you think they're so
underrated and that you really love
listening to them and you have to leave
it up for 24 hours
what do I get if I win you get you get a
pic I don't know man but you know what
I'm gonna beat you all right so if I win
I get to actually play you for a full
game of ten [ __ ] that's all you want
yeah yeah cuz I want to be able to play
like a real game okay twenty years a man
of simple needs I think I got smoky if I
played for an hour
noobs I do not think though oh
absolutely
I'm giving you a run for Manny right now
look at these girls I've only played 10
minutes and I'm almost good yet you
think you'd smoke me that's hilarious
that is holy Dylan okay okay so if I win
IFO Spice Girls if you win you get the
glory of beating me yeah and we'll play
for a full game of ten okay one two
three in a powerful position
[Applause]
[Music]
okay all right so it's a wash again
sweating
that's hot so what are your Instagram
followers gonna think when they see oh
no no that's not like a big deal cuz I
like all kinds of music way they're not
gonna be like oh yeah he actually likes
the spice oh yeah I could I mean I like
all kinds of stuff
wait do you actually like the Spice
Girls no I don't even know I'm just
saying they wouldn't be like what cuz I
I post so much different music really
yeah yeah I'm not just some Rob man I
feel like Spice Girls is so like deeply
out of your well I mean taste I like
Adele yeah man I mean who doesn't
if you don't like Adele then you're just
dead inside one two three that's so
funny I thought that me having Spice
Girls on there would like devastate you
like whatever you know what time it is
oh here he is here he comes
flip the disk with that one oh yeah okay
so that's a wash with that one then yeah
the first one all right all right ready
1 2 3
[ __ ] you scored both of those yeah I was
about to talk [ __ ] and maybe I should
focus first one two three Cheers
I really am sweaty this is intense one I
was gonna ask if you felt like your age
is coming into play [ __ ] every time I go
to talk smack 20 scores okay I'm just
I'm never gonna say that full sentence
because like karma telling me to show
the feel it in my bones here we go oh
that's just good defense No so how's
that feel old man I was fun man I love
this game you love it as much as I do
that's like you know I don't meet that
many other people especially other
comedians that well especially now in
this is so analog yeah it's still
thriving so much there's still so many
big tournaments out there and looks more
players than ever before and as long as
you got white trash you're gonna have
fun oh I find from such white trash yeah
I'm very very proud to be well thank you
so much I'm coming I'm letting me just
kick your ass I feel so yeah yeah you
didn't kick my I think you're right man
I hadn't played in 20 years I feel sorry
for you if I played for like a week go
Rocky it up go run some steps tiny
little running these aren't rooms come
back in a week and we'll play again what
are you writing a novel
there's a little laughing yeah okay this
is what I just posted on Dean's
Instagram account and by the way his
Instagram account is just like full of
like all these like rock lead singers
it's very like his brand I just posted a
picture of the spine shows and said most
people might not know this about me but
I'm a huge Spice Girls fan I love
listening to them before I hit the stage
to pump myself up do it and want to be
our personal favorites spice up your
life baby
peace sign emoji and kissy face emoji
but I'm gonna pull up Kelsie cook just
cheated that way let me get a picture of
us and I'm gonna put up Kelsey Cook
definitely cheated all right guys thank
you for watching another episode of
Rissa fury Thank You Dean for letting me
just kick that ass here's hello to your
old camera cheater oh Jesus whatever
whatever you need to tell yourself good
feel better we're gonna play another
game for fun and we will see you guys on
the next episode